at this altitude I can run flat-out for
my hands this episode is brought to you
by four Sigma deck
you might remember four sig Matic for
their mushroom coffee which was created
by those clever Finnish founders and
when I first mentioned that coffee on
this podcast the products sold out in
less than a week it lights you up like a
Christmas tree which can be really
useful however recently I've been
testing the opposite side of the
spectrum a new product and that is their
reishi mushroom elixir to help me end my
day to get to sleep as you guys may know
longtime listeners at least I struggled
with insomnia for decades I have a
largely fixed that but still shutting
off my monkey brain has never been easy
still isn't easy very often and I found
reishi which have been fascinated by for
a few years now has been very very
effective and calming their old formula
however for sig Maddox old formula
included stevia and I like to avoid
sweeteners all sweeteners for a host of
reasons and I then just ping them and
asked hey guys
I would love to experiment with this and
maybe actually suggest it but I'd like a
version without sweeteners if you'd be
open to it if too much of headache don't
worry and they are always game for
experimentation so they created a
special custom version without the
stevia without sweeteners now it is part
of my nightly routine their ratio elixir
comes in single serving packets which
are perfect for travel and in fact I'm
about to leave the country right now and
I have a packet in front of me that's
just gonna sit in the end of my carry-on
bag
you only need hot water and it mixes
very very easily here's some recommended
copy that they put in the read so I'm
gonna read it and I'll give you my take
quote a warning for those in the
experimental mindset reishi is strong
and bitter in parentheses like any great
medicine so if the bitterness is too
much I recommend trying it with honey
and or nutmilk such as almond milk &
quot so I'm gonna say no you should suck
it up and you should drink the tea
because it's not that bitter and maybe
you should take the advice of all
Chinese people when they're criticizing
young uns when they say boo and I'm sure
they're cool which means you're not able
to eat bitterness bitter is in many
cases an indication of things that help
liver detoxification and so on not
saying that's the case here but I've
tested this ratio later on family
members on friends everybody has liked
it it's a little bit earthy it's not
that hard so I would just say suck it up
and know don't put it in honey or not
milk or any of that [ __ ] just drink the
goddamn tea it's delicious I think right
if you like poo air that kind of stuff
that type of tea you're gonna dig it so
just try it okay back to then my read if
you'd like to naturally improve your
sleep both on set and quality I think
naturally you might just enjoy this
ratio lecture without any sweeteners it
has organic reishi extract organic
fueled mint extract organic rosehips
extract organic Tulsi extract and that's
it no fancy stuff no artificial
whatchamacallit anything so check it out
go to four sigma tech comm forward slash
ferrous and get 20% off this special
batch I don't know if they're gonna be
making much more of this since it was
made specifically for you guys so do me
a favor and try it out so that they
continue to be open to experimenting
with me to create products for you guys
specifically check it out for sig Matic
that's fo you are SI g ma t IC comm /e
ferrous f e RR ISS and get 20% off the
special batch and you must use the code
a ferrous to receive your discount fer
AR ISS so again go to four sig Metacom
forward slash ferrous and then use code
ferrous for 20% off of this rare
exclusive limited run of reishi mushroom
elixir for nighttime routines without
any sweeteners enjoy
this episode is brought to you by we
work I love we work I haven't had an
office in many many many many many years
since 2000 or so when I had my last real
job exposed and quotation marks but when
I moved from San Francisco to Austin not
long ago I decided you know what I'm
tired of working at home I'm tired of
working in coffee shops so one of the
very first things I did was to get a
space at we work I could not be happier
with this change in my life we work is a
global network of work spaces where
companies and people grow together the
idea is really simple you focus on your
business and we work takes care of all
of the rest including front desk service
utilities refreshments and more I also
often have things shipped from Amazon
and elsewhere to my office that we work
here in Austin I've been completely
blown away by the members-only events
special offers and perhaps the best cold
brew coffee on tap that I've ever had
it's been amazing it's been a real real
change in my life and improved my
quality of life and there are also dog
friendly we work locations all over the
place how fun is that we work caters to
everyone from entrepreneurs and
freelancers to startups and even large
enterprises including GE Salesforce
Microsoft MasterCard Samsung Spotify
Pinterest and redbull among many others
in fact more than 10% of Fortune 500
companies currently use we work and it's
a rapidly growing group in other words
it's not just solar printers and
ground-level startups that use we work
but everything from that to the big
companies who are seeing very huge
benefits as well we work believes that
creating spaces where people can connect
and create meaning together right and
after all if you are someone who has
built a business modeled on the
principles in the 4-hour workweek or
elsewhere it can be a lonely road
sometimes even though you're digitally
connected it can feel very very
isolating
so in these spaces you can connect with
real humans and all the while use space
more efficiently and cost-effectively
which makes you and your business better
equipped to face the challenges of today
and tomorrow
we work now has more than 200 locations
so you can find great spots all over the
world so head over to we co forward
slash Tim that's weed Co Co so we that
co forward slash Tim to become a part of
the global we work community at the very
least I encourage you to check out
pictures of some of the locations around
the world there are some incredible
spots so check it out we Co forward
slash Tim low boys and girls this is Tim
Barris and welcome to another episode of
the Tim Ferriss show my guest today is
Daniel H pink at Daniel pink on Twitter
he is the author of six provocative
books including his newest when subtitle
the scientific secrets of perfect timing
when is a New York Times Wall Street
Journal USA Today Washington Post n
Publishers Weekly bestseller that's a
lot of lists Pink's other books include
the long-running New York Times
bestseller a whole new mind and the
number one New York Times bestsellers
drive and to sell is human his books
have won multiple awards and have been
translated into 37 languages at last
count he lives in Washington DC with his
family you can also find his work his
various goings on at Dan pink command if
Facebook is your thing facebook.com
forward slash Daniel H pink Dan welcome
to the show Tim thanks for having me it
has been quite a while since we are here
several years and I know we were talking
about all things Japanese most likely at
least in in one of our recent
conversations but on one of your books
and maybe you could tell people actually
just as context a little bit about that
book that we were chatting about in
manga format or Japanese comic format
and will use that as a jumping off point
yes indeed that was one of my best ideas
that didn't go anywhere so that was a
book called The Adventures of Johnny
Bunco and and as you say Tim it was
written in the Japanese comic format
known as manga and as you know as a
Japanophile
in Japan manga the comic format is is
much more versatile and more widely
use that it is here in the United States
so so you've grown-ups reading comics
and it can be things about financial
advice things about love life things
about history and so I did a fellowship
in Japan with my wife and our three kids
where I study the manga industry and I
came back and said you know what I think
it's time for manga to broaden its reach
here in the United States of America so
I wrote a book called The Adventures of
Johnny Bunco and it's a graphic novel in
manga form that reveals the six
essential lessons of any satisfying
productive career through the story of a
hapless young accountant named Johnny
Bunco that was a fantastically concise
description and I wanted to also you
said in the beginning that it was the
best idea that didn't go anywhere or
something along those lines and yeah I
wanted to bring up the book because it
seems for those people it struck a chord
with it struck a very deep chord and I
believe it was Kevin Kelley arguably the
most interesting man in the world
who was on this biasted and he mentioned
that that book was at least at the time
his most gifted book so I wanted to at
least highlight the fact that if it's
good enough for Kevin Kelley it should
be good enough for many many other
people that's like that's exactly right
now kevin has Kevin did say that and I
actually think it's a good book we did
reasonably well with it it didn't blow
off the doors I think I was you know
this is this is a common thing that
happens in life and in investing in
entrepreneurship and publishing and
anything is that you could be right too
early I think that's what it was that
that I actually think that this format
of graphic novels and comics having a
more expansive reach in the United
States is probably going to happen I
might have been as they would say my in
in the world of politics I might have
been a little ahead of the voters or
using a surfing metaphor paddling a
little too early for the wave which
right right which sometimes means you
don't catch a wave and investing it
sometimes mean use paddle right into the
impact zone and then
get smashed now you mentioned you
mentioned politics I wasn't gonna go
here right away oh boy
but and I'm going to get there in two
hops but so I'm looking at in front of
me the Yale Law and Policy Review vol 8
number 2 1990 and it says job this is
like it's like a deposition now what do
you have like exhibit a I might gonna
say something you're gonna make me right
now I'm auditioning indirectly I'll be
it for my role on truTV as today but
this won't go into any incriminating
territory unless you volunteer or
something along those lines which I
which I doubt will happen but it says on
top editor-in-chief Daniel H pink so how
did fate intervene that you are not
currently in the legal profession oh my
god this is one area where I want to
thank fate for her grace and kindness
here's the thing I went to law school
and I went to law school largely because
I was a middle-class kid from the middle
of America and that's kind of what you
did and once I started saw the inside
and it was a terrible decision and it
actually helped me figure out how to
make better decisions um it gave me some
actually really good advice on how to
make better decisions but I basically
went to law school without knowing what
lawyers did or even what law school was
it was just something I did because
that's what I was supposed to do I found
out I didn't really like it very much
and I and once I found out what lawyers
actually did and God bless the lawyers
listening to this but once I find out
what lawyers actually did I was like oh
you you hire somebody else to do that
you know it's like like you know it's
like it's I mean it's like it takes like
it takes skill of the like plunge a
toilet or you know you know that kind of
thing or you know you mow a gigantic
backyard I mean it takes skill to do
that it's just that you know what it's
really not my thing and so what I'd
rather do is do something else and then
pay someone else to do that kind of
dirty work and yet I found myself stuck
and because I was risk-averse and I did
leave for a little while actually I
dropped out for a little while but I
came back and
so I went to law so I went to law school
it wasn't a you know Greg accumulated
massive massive massive massive student
loans but I was very fortunate in
two-dimensions in my law school
trajectory one was that my school had a
very head of its time loan payback
program keyed to salary so if you made
less than a certain amount they would
offer assistance in repaying your
student loans and that gave people much
more nobody not many people took it but
that gave you theoretically more career
flexibility if you decided not to
practice law the other thing is that I
met my wife in law school so it's um
that's a decision that ended up having a
profound positive effect on my life how
did it help you learn to make better
decisions going to law school right
right you said those well here's the
thing okay you know here's what it did
here's what I did here's the thing okay
so there's this principle in social
science it has a fancy name but it is
something that we all do and something
we should do is a principle of surrogacy
okay how do you make decisions you use
the principle of surrogate and surrogacy
basically means find someone like you
who made this decision and see what
happened to him or her
that is find out what it's really like
it's again this is a totally fancified
way of something that is very
commonsensical what you know should I go
to this restaurant well let me check the
Yelp reviews of 47 other people who've
gone to this restaurant and what I did
amazing to meet Tim when I think about
this and it's advice that I give to my
own kids as well I went to law school
literally having never spent a day not a
day 10 minutes talking to a lawyer I
went to law school having never sat in
on a law school class I'm it's
unbelievable to me in retrospect and and
so had I done those kinds of things I
might have approached it more
skeptically but I didn't do those things
and so and and because that ended up
being an incredibly expensive decision
even though it led to some pot you know
it basically I mean it led to the most
positive thing in my life which is my
wife even though it led to
something positive it was a terrible
decision so now I'm sort of a Asura
Gatien ideologue
you know it's like I believe in ceará
Gatien for everything largely because I
got bitten by that bad decision could
you give us an example of at some fork
in the road or some prospective decision
where you've used surrogacy or where
you're planning on using
okay so I'll give you an example of it
so yeah it's you know again we're not
talking rocket science here we're
talking like basically hey act like a
reasonably intelligent grown-up
is what I'm you know it's basically what
I'm doing here but let's go back to the
let's go back to the Japan I think I saw
I got a fellowship to go to Japan and I
went with my wife and her and her kids
as I mentioned but before I did that I
talked to you know six different people
who had the same fellowship before I
accepted six different people who had
the same fellowship what it was like for
their kids what was what the work was
like what the living was like before I
made the decision now again that is not
a monumental intellectual breakthrough
but it's something that I didn't do when
I was much younger well it's a best
practice that can often get skipped
right whether that's something like this
or something this should be very
straightforward if you look at say Atul
Gawande zhh work and the checklist
manifesto and checking various things to
avoid bacterial line infections in a
hospital right it's very straightforward
but if you neglect it over yeah I'm bad
things are going to happen but it's also
the you know I think that as as I've
gotten older and gotten more experience
I've actually become much more aware of
the importance of intellectual humility
and like what you know when I think of
when I was younger I feel well I know
what if law school is like how do you
know I just know because I thought about
it once and so I know I know what
lawyers do because like I met somebody
who's a lawyer and I know what the
lawyers you know and so there's a degree
of arrogance and that I was thinking
that you know something when you
actually don't and so if you approach
all kinds of decisions with a degree of
intellectual humility and ask yourself
what
don't I know about this we're on my
blind spots then I think you end up
making better decisions
definitely speaking of blind spots I
promised a segue into politics and that
is somewhere I have very very little
confidence in any of my knowledge or
expertise how did you so I was looking
at what I believed to be one of the
first articles that really I'm not gonna
say put you on the map that's too too
much of an overstatement but the the
free-agent nation article in Fast
Company which was at the yeah end of
nineteen twenty years ago yeah 1997 and
in the bio or the byline rather of that
article says until recently chief
speechwriter to Vice President Al Gore
so where did you go from law school or
dropping out of law school for a period
of time to speech writing for then Vice
President Al Gore well when I graduated
from law school I was actually very
keenly interested in politics
it was probably my deepest interest at
the time and I said you know what I'm
gonna go where I'm gonna work in
politics I think why was the posting to
you at the time a couple of reasons
number one is that I thought it was a
venue for for achieving something in the
world and making a contribution to the
world the other thing is that I found
the actual practice of it quite exciting
and interesting in the way that Sports
is exciting and interesting so it's a
combo platter for me and and I've been
interested in for many many years and I
said okay this is this is what is what I
want to do so I got out of law school
and I started working on political
campaigns which at the time I liked
because political campaigns are totally
interesting I mean again it's like a
sport in that there's its you know
there's a beginning and there's an end
and there's a clear clear outcome and
it's exciting and you're making
decisions on the fly
and I find political campaigns more than
other kinds of organizations and
institutions fairly meritocratic because
there's so much going on it's so much
crazy stuff happening that if you can do
something you will continue you'll
you'll be asked to do it again and
that's pretty much what happened to me
and that someone at some point asked me
to write a speech and I did it and it
was okay and then they said hey that's
okay you want to do it again and I did
it again and then I did
a third time all of a sudden that was my
job and you know it ended up being
something that I had a certain affinity
for and and it's something that a lot of
other people did not and so just in the
supply and demand of who has to do what
that's what I ended up doing and I
enjoyed it I did it on political
campaigns I did it for a cabinet
secretary and then I ended up doing it
for the I ended up doing it for the vice
president and the trouble was is that
when I had spent all these years in the
belly of the beast you know it's sort of
like wow I really want to work in
politics and all of a sudden in a pretty
kind of half-assed way I was at a pretty
good gig in the belly of the beast I
realized hey I'm not sure this is my
thing I thought this is my thing but I'm
discovering that this is not my thing
and what's even worse is that if I
project out even further and look at say
what I'm gonna be like or what I'm gonna
be doing in ten years or 20 years I
really don't like that picture because I
see some of those people around me now
what is there anything besides the
projecting forward looking at the people
who had been in the game so to speak for
a longer period of time and saying wow I
could see myself filling their shoes and
I don't like what that looks like
was there anything else any other
indicators or moments that made you
realize it wasn't for you there are a
few things first of all the the amount
of BS that was involved was startling to
me I expected some but the if you do -
if you do a pie chart of BS and not BS
the BS slice Jordan was extraordinarily
large larger than larger than you would
larger than you would imagine on a
number of different dimensions and
here's the thing to him
I freaking lucked out - and who I was
working for because my last two jobs I
worked for Al Gore who's a very smart
guy and a very good guy all around and
the before that I worked for the then
Labor Secretary as a speechwriter for
the then Labor Secretary guy named
Robert rice who's a very smart guy
good god so I had basically the best
kinds of bosses you could possibly have
and so that was another indication like
I got the best bosses you could possibly
have and I still like hmm it's not the
species of rice or gore I don't like
it's the genus of politics that is
actually bringing me down you know and
so and so among the things that I didn't
like let's go back to the BS there was
an enormous amount of enormous amount of
time spent basically in the air in
almost everything that was going on
within the boundaries of the law is
concern for basically pandering and
fundraising it was really quite
remarkable the other thing is that I
also felt like a lot of let a lot of the
people who were good people that they
were so interested they were so absorbed
in the mechanics of things that they I
felt like I was losing sight over like
what we were doing here in the first
place
right what did we actually what do we
actually believe in that the and there
was so much short term ISM so much short
term insane kind of posturing and and
let's get this slight advantage over the
day and and it was like what's the point
you know what's the point of all this
I'm working really really hard and I'm
not sure this is I'm not sure we're
actually doing that much and here's a
scary part it's like that was 20 years
ago
in retrospect those are the good old
days all right I mean you have you have
I mean you know we were I mean I'm old
enough I did this long enough ago where
I would be I'd be pumped when something
I wrote made it on to the the
quote-unquote evening news I haven't
watched the evening news for 19 years
you know we weren't dealing with social
media the world was very very very
partisan and but nothing like the way it
is now
so I remember devoting a couple of days
in my office to some subpoena that was
given to Gore's office for finding some
document about some nonsense thing and
I'm like and I'm like really concerned
about that because I didn't do anything
wrong but it's like oh my god if I have
an email that mentions X Y or Z and they
don't find it and then
someone else finds it like I'm gonna
have to hire a lawyer and I didn't sign
up for this garbage so so I finally
decided to I finally did yeah so so
again this thing that I thought I was
deeply deeply interested in once I
actually experienced it I found myself
far less interested in it then then I
would have suspected if you had told me
that when I left that job if you had
told me ten years earlier you're gonna
have this job and you're gonna leave it
because you're tired of politics I would
have been very very surprised if you if
you look back at that experience the
skills you either had natively or
developed how do you prepare your
speeches now or maybe if we take an
example of a speech that you've given
that has received very positive feedback
or really from your perspective engaged
the audience how do you go about
preparing a 30 minutes 60 minute speech
what does what does that look like is
there any example that you can give us
yeah I mean it depends I mean actually
that experience writing speeches was
actually extraordinarily useful in going
out and you know being a writer and then
going out and talking about what I've
written about I mean it's
extraordinarily useful I mean if if for
no other reason Tim it was because you
know I spent a lot of time as a speech
writer watching audiences react saying
what worked and what seeing what worked
and what did it and that I think has a
completely left an imprint on me again I
was able you know I had this before I
went out on doing it myself I spent you
know as much time as any human being
could have done like watching speeches
being given but I always would watch
whenever when any of my bosses would
give a speech I would actually watch the
audience rather than my boss to see
because that's how I learned how to get
better at it
hey that line works hey that lines a dud
hey they're spacing out here hey this
this person over here looks confused Wow
this went on too long Wow this could
have gone on a little I've never had
experience that could
longer but you know this but we could
have we could have we could have we
could have cut it out there and so so
seeing audiences react just gave me I'm
it's hard it's almost like think of an
analogy here okay I mean this is an
imperfect analogy but it's almost like
I'm gonna go basically walk up and down
the streets of Santiago Chile for a
couple of years I'm not gonna do any
talking but I'm gonna listen to
everybody else talking and it's like
whoa you can learn some Spanish that way
it's not gonna be you're not going to be
perfectly Spanish but you have a huge
advantage of someone if you do that and
then go and say hey I'm think I'm gonna
learn how to speak Spanish it also makes
me think of a very useful feature for
potential speakers although it's
probably not worth the labor for the Ted
organization would be to take the
cameras see that's always pointed at the
audience and give you the option of
listening to TED Talks while watching
the audience respond that's an
interesting idea that's an interesting
idea I mean they they do cutaways on
those kinds of things but the cutaways
don't show people being bored right
exactly that's actually that's actually
more revealing than anything anything
else and I'll tell you like from the
speech givers point of view and it's
interesting you you raise this Tim
because I haven't really thought a huge
amount about it myself but one of the
things that I enjoy most about giving
talks is seeing the audience's reaction
and figuring out what's good and what
isn't so if I come up with hey I got
this killer line I just thought of this
is gonna totally rule and then I deliver
it it's like whoa that bombed and in my
head I don't feel like oh I'm so sad
that it bombed but in the back of my
head I'm like ah that bomb that's so
interesting I got to make a note of that
of like that one bomb you know and why
is why did that one bomb do people not
understand it was it was it obnoxious
and so I love that
part of and when you give speeches when
you do something in real time with
people there really anything before an
audience so if you and I were talking
before a live audience we would be
getting feedback on her conversation
that I would that I think would be
really useful and interesting and when
you do things that are asynchronous as
we're doing now we're writing a book
which is asynchronous you get that
feedback much later and so the feedback
is less is less meaningful so if I if I
write something and someone says you
wrote this passage here I just don't get
it that's sort of a bummer for me
because I don't have time to cure it but
if I say something before an audience
and I get a bunch of blank looks I
immediately know Wow okay I didn't
explain that very well I got to go back
next time around and get explain it
better so i I've so many different
questions I want to dig into related to
what you just said the first is actually
connected to something we were talking
about just before we hit record and that
was you having listened to the interview
I did with Brian Koppelman the screen
gunner filmmaker a co-creator of the the
hit show billions among many other
things and his penchant and
recommendation for forensic ly studying
film watching films with a notebook in
hand and taking notes on what worked
what didn't his responses and so on and
you you mentioned a number of different
questions and cues that you might ask
yourself while watching in your
speechwriter days the audience while
you're this essentially your boss is
giving a talk would you mind writing
those things down it would be would you
be sitting there kind of with a notebook
in hand recording this this type of
thing what I would be what I would often
be doing would be I would have okay so
if I had a it was a speech where I had a
written where there was a written text
which is not always the case in some
cases for for lower key for less
significant things it would be say you
know a conversation and some talking
points and some things
like that you know that but let's say
for speech that was actually deliver
that is a speech that was written out
and then delivered you know behind a
podium I would almost always have the
actual physical text of the speech and I
would mark up that physical text of it
so so in some cases because it was
helpful for me in terms of just relating
to my own boss let's say that he skipped
a paragraph I like my wonder I skipped
that paragraph you know maybe asking
about that or maybe I could even figure
out why I skipped that you know he
didn't even bother reading a paragraph
or he skipped a line or he ad-libbed
adieu to a new version of the line that
was actually very helpful to me in terms
of just dealing with my boss because
again what you're trying to do in
writing a speech for somebody else is
that you're trying to make that person
sound like the best version of him or
herself and so it could be that the way
I phrase something didn't sound like him
but he knew what I meant and he was able
to phrase it in his own words and that
and that actually was helpful for me in
terms of doing the the the tactical
craft of my job but so I would have that
I would have the text with me let's say
there was a joke you know I would say I
mean it basically it would look like
plus if I'm in series like plus and
minus you know and say hey that joke
worked that joke didn't work that line
worked at that line that line didn't
work and one of the things that it
taught me was also is that you don't go
based on I'm getting in the weeds here a
little bit but you don't make permanent
decisions based on one reaction and I do
that myself now in my own stuff so if I
say something and it doesn't work the
first time I don't say I don't abandon
it then I make a note of that and then I
try it again
because sometimes different audiences
different contexts different things it
can work but so but yeah I would do that
it was just sort of you know and here's
the thing I don't want to make this
sound like like I used the word forensic
to talk about what compliment is doing
mine was less forensic it was more
hygienic it was two medias like that's
just like good staff hygiene you know I
you know what I mean I wrote a speech
and in this dude is delivering it I
should pay attention to like how it's
going you know
and if I do that if I do that I'm gonna
do better next time and he's gonna do
better Exxon if I look at the my own
writing the writing that I've done that
has has received the best response well
let's keep it broad nine times out of
ten it's something that I have tested
and honed in some speaking format
whether it's a presentation or a class
or something else which is part of the
reason why if if I'm giving a talk or
doing an interview in front of a live
audience I always ask them to raise the
houselights because for whatever reason
a lot of venues like sure really dim it
down but then you can't see the response
so I always raise the house lights when
you are testing out a speech or an
article or a chapter on someone else
what types of question what are you
looking for or what types of questions
do you ask you can pick any of those
that you'd like but guys do yeah yeah
yeah yeah let me take your simple
question and complicated
let's go because I because I actually
think that that speeches and written
words are different things okay and so
so the way that I would convey an idea
in a speech is going to be different
from the way that I would convey the
similar same idea in a book and so so so
you know so so for me like one of the
most important to say it's it's a simple
question but and I find myself asking it
all the time to people is this following
question does that make sense does that
make sense or what I've sometimes found
an easier way to rephrase that is this
is actually I think it's actually useful
writing Act is what about that doesn't
make sense yes I think some people
praise I think that people I think that
people are more likely to say does that
make sense they're you know sort of out
of politeness and also just out of self
oh of course I make sense oh yeah yeah
you know but sort of what about that so
I converted a little bit what about that
what about that doesn't make sense with
when you give us when you when
when you explain an idea to somebody or
you're talking to an audience I really
think I mean maybe I'm overestimating my
own abilities but I really think you can
tell by the look on people's faces
they're all other kinds of markers of
that too so for instance you know
especially now do you have slides what
are people taking pictures of all right
what slides are they taking pictures of
what things are they writing down so I
look at those kinds of cues in in in in
talks I think writing is is more
difficult and I'll tell you what I do in
writing especially books and this is a
little bit insane or it's I mean it's
insane in the sense that you requires it
requires someone who is deeply devoted
to you in a way that someone you truly
love is devoted to you so here's the
here's the thing about my books I even
though I'm even though I just said
speeches and written words are different
for me I actually improved my writing by
listening to it not because I listened
to written words different from the way
I listened to speeches if that makes any
sense
and so when I write books so the latest
book I mean you know latest book and all
the previous books I have an office here
behind my house in Washington DC it's a
garage refurbished garage and for I will
sit in my office and I give it looks
like what the latest book okay just to
give you an idea so this is a book I
don't know it's like 280 pages something
like that I read every word of that book
out loud to my wife at various stages
what's what's more I read drafts
multiple drafts of chapters out loud to
my wife in this office but wait there's
more my wife read every word of this
book out loud to me including drafts
because for me that's how I that's how I
process the that's how I process the
written word so for me I can tell what
works in a speech because you have a
large audience of people the
you know reacting to it when in terms of
written words like I I don't know it's
just like I you know after all these
years I know what's good and what's not
when it comes to written word and I
actually know what's not good really is
what I know and so I try to remove all
the not good stuff and and with the way
I do that and there's a very laborious
way is to read aloud because that helps
me look at the words a different way but
also to have them read aloud to me now
what's amazing to this and shows you
just how incredible and awesome my wife
is that I am the worst person on the
planet to be read aloud to because I'm a
complete pain in the ass when it comes
to especially if you're reading my my
words oh come on you got to read more
expression than that oh come on no the
emphasis is on that word my my saintly
wife has done this for several several
several books now Wow she's a keeper
I so if i've only and i suspect this is
more common than either of us might
expect but John McPhee the nonfiction
writer also writes I think he still
writes for The New Yorker fascinating
guy but I took a seminar with him in
undergrad and he also explained how he
reads all of his work I believe he reads
not only his feature works but his
articles out loud to his wife really I
actually did not know that yep yep this
is yeah so I'm pretty good and I'm in
I'm in pretty good company
I started reading I started reading John
McPhee when I was like a like a pretty
you know like a young teenager and one
of the best McPhee books I've read was a
book you might have read it called
levels of the game you know I was it's
so good I get so so good maybe you can
read it again again about two years ago
but I read it I read it as a kid you
know I got it out of library I spent a
lot of time in libraries when I was kid
and and I don't know how some library
or somebody told me about it because
there was a because he had that famous
book about Bill Bradley a sense of where
you are so I read that because I was a
basketball fan and then it's like oh I
was also a tennis fan it's like oh you
wrote about tennis too and I read that
book and I didn't you know at the time I
guess I was I was saying wow you can
actually write about sports in a way
that's kind of more interesting than
just sports that's a remarkable book I
mean I can explain it quick so it's it's
a story about a match between a single
tennis match between Arthur Ashe who
would then was very young just out of
Richmond and a guy named Clark Graebner
who was from a wealthier
white guy wealthier family in I think it
was like suburban Cleveland and what he
does is he basically describes the match
but throughout he pulls back and tells
each of their stories of how they
actually got to the court that day I
think it was the US Open a US Open match
and so he actually describes them
playing a point and then he pulls back
and talks about how Arthur Ashe got
there and he pulls back and talks about
how Clark Graebner got there and he does
it with such elegance and such concision
it's just that that's a it's a joy to
behold it's it's truly spectacular and
for those who haven't read McPhee you
should if not for any other reason that
he can take any subject matter you can
imagine and make a riveting book about
said subject it could be oranges
Plymouth Rock yeah cars I know and cars
canoes geology it just you name the
topic and he can turn it into a page
turner but levels levels of the game is
is just spectacular and one one thing
that McPhee is very very good at is and
I think this is also shared territory
with you is asking questions it given
the nature of his writing a very
significant portion of his time is spent
interviewing and what about that doesn't
make sense
is a really powerful tweak on the maybe
alternative that you mentioned which is
does this make sense right or does this
make sense or not and I this this maybe
digging too far into the weeds but I was
really
fascinated to read about an approach
that you've detailed in one of your
books called motivational interviewing
and I and I hadn't heard of this before
but the the example that stuck out to me
and you don't have to give this exact
example but was asking a student who is
seemingly struggling with algebra a
[Music]
certain question instead of others I
don't want to butcher it but I can
certainly also I have it in front of me
so I can pull it up if need be but can
you explain for people what motivational
interviewing is and maybe give an
example yes so this is actually a it's
it's a therapeutic technique that
actually I I think has wider
applications and I heard about it from a
fella named Mike pantalon who's that at
the Yale School of Medicine who used it
in in I think addiction addiction
treatment and it's basically like this
so let's say that let's say that you
have let me think of a good example here
something that somebody typically isn't
that keen to do okay let's say let's
let's let's go to out but let's say you
have somebody let's say you're a parent
you have a kid who's in eighth grade and
he has an algebra test and doesn't wanna
study for the algebra test isn't into it
doesn't want to do it and so you know
typical reaction from parents from
anybody and authority figure it's like
what the hell is wrong you know you know
start saying she's sort of demanding
start demanding compliance and
motivational interviewing is almost the
reverse of that so it basically so let's
say you have a kid named Bob you could
say you know hey Bob I see you're not
studying for your algebra test let me
ask you a question on you know I see you
have an algebra test tomorrow
on this on a scale of one to ten how
ready are you to study for your algebra
test how ready you to start studying for
your algebra test all right how much do
you want to start setting for your
algebra test and Bob is totally
unmotivated by Bob might say I'm a three
all right a three out of ten
now again our reaction is bosses as
parents as people and figures of
authority as basically is to say what do
you mean your
three you should be enough you know but
instead you're more chill than that and
you say okay you're three why didn't you
pick a lower number and that always not
always weeks people asked he says I'm a
three out of ten in terms of my desire
to do this thing and you say instead of
saying you oh my god you should be a
nine what are you crazy you lazy ass you
say oh why don't you pick a lower number
and what's interesting about that is
that is what it does to Bob is that bob
has to now say why he's not a two and so
he begins saying things like well you
know if I don't study for this test I'm
probably gonna bomb the next test if I
don't master this material it's gonna be
harder to go into later on if I don't do
well in this test you might have some me
and so what happens is is that Bob
begins articulating his own autonomous
intrinsically motivated reasons for
doing something and that's the key and
what we know from a mountain of social
science research is that when people
have their own reasons for doing
something they're more likely to endorse
the behavior and they're more likely to
carry it out and so this becomes a way
to surface Bob's own motivation for it
through questions rather than through
rather than through dictates and it can
be a very very powerful technique you
can also turn it inward you know you say
well how how how ready are you Dan to
finish this chapter of God you know I'm
like a three then you say well then why
aren't why aren't you - oh you know and
so anything you can do to help people
surface their own reasons for doing
something makes them more likely to
commit to the behavior more likely to
follow through on the behavior that last
extension is really important I had been
prepping this and reading the background
some of it and it didn't even occur to
me that you could apply it to yourself
and use it for journaling or something
like that to incur or maybe rediscover
the motivation that drove you to start
it in the first place even though you
lost sight of it or a petered out or
whatever the hell it might be yeah I
mean you could use it for going to use
it you could use it for you could use it
for going to the you know going to the
gym or going to going to work out like
how like you know how ready are you how
ha you know how excited are you about
I'm motivated already to work out right
now I'm a - alright well I said it's
myself
aren't you one well you know I know that
probably I'll feel better if I work out
Ryland if I don't work out I know that
actually if I don't do this aerobic
exercise today I'm probably gonna you
know might not have a chance to do it
tomorrow which means I'm gonna feel like
crap and so you can you can turn it on
yourself as well it's all about those
surfacing you know you know one of the
things that we've done in turn in
management and parenting and all in all
other realms of life is that we have
over
we've overdosed on control and control
is not an effective way to motivate
people for important things because
human beings only have two responses to
control they comply or they defy and
that's a history of humankind it's
basically human beings either complying
or defying with control and so we get me
to abandon control as a motivator and
look for ways for people to summon their
own autonomous motivation for doing
things so we talked at the very top of
this interview about Johnny Bunco and
how you were ahead of the voters in a
sense didn't quite catch you might have
been a bit early with the manga format
in contrast a whole new mind seems to
really have resonated strongly and it
did catch so I'd love to try to
deconstruct of why that was the case and
as one example its appealed so much to
over when for this she gifted I want to
say 4500 copies to the Stanford
graduating class of 2008 when she did
her commencement speech there why do you
think that is and the subtitle I should
just mention so holding mine subtitle
why right-brainers will rule the future
why did this one take yeah I mean it's
it's it's hard to say I think a reason
that it took is that it was a fairly
original idea conveyed in a way that was
easy to understand and also had the
advantage of probably being more right
than wrong so so the idea in that book
it's the following that I was arguing
then I still believe it today that the
structure of our brain offers a metaphor
for describing
the future of work and the you know all
your listeners know there's been a lot
of stuff written about left brain and
right brain over the years most of its
just total garbage but one of the one of
what we know about our brains is that
they're actually somewhat efficient and
then over time they've divided up tasks
so the left hemisphere specializes in
one set of tasks tacit or logical linear
sequential analytical the right
hemisphere specializes in a different
set of tasks tasks that are about
understanding context about synthesis
and about simultaneous processing and so
that division of labor in the brain I
think offers a very powerful metaphor
for understanding what what what I
thought was going on in the world of
work and it continues to go into the
world of work but actually to make sure
I got the underlying science right in a
tearing a page from the Tim Ferriss
playbook I actually went to the National
Institutes of Health to get my own brain
scanned see my own brain in action which
ended up being profoundly disappointing
experience but that's another story for
another day
and so basically the idea here is this
that the abilities that used to be the
most valuable in the economy
characteristic it's a metaphor
characteristic of the left hemisphere
logical linear sequential analytical
spreadsheet as a TIA bilities those
abilities are still necessary but
they're no longer sufficient and its
abilities more characteristic of the
right hemisphere of the brain artistry
empathy inventiveness big-picture
thinking those abilities are now the
first among equals and the reason for
that is that is a very hard headed
reason that those kinds of abilities are
easy to outsource easy to automate and
that the left hemisphere ability sorry
the left hemisphere abilities the SAT
spreadsheet abilities are easy to
outsource easy to automate and less
valuable in iterating something new in
dealing with the demands for new that
comes from an abundant world and so and
so I actually maybe another reason that
took is that I basically came to a soft
hardened conclusion in a hard-headed way
there was a very clear economic argument
for that you know the three A's aja
automation abundance reductive left
brain work can be done cheaper overseas
the other a automation it can be done
faster by computers and now smart
machines and then finally abundance that
our material needs have been satisfied
and over satisfied that there's a
premium now in coming up with something
utterly new and giving the world
something it didn't know it was missing
which is a very much of an artistic
ability and so that's the argument in
that book and it's an argument I think
that people resonated too because they
were seeing Inklings in their own life
and they needed a way to describe it
categorize it put words on it well it
seems like history has proven your
prediction or description very accurate
at this point for sure and it also would
also curse to me that this is this is
another place in manga aside were you
and Kevin Kelly the founding editor of
Wired magazine very much on the same
page you mentioned something in passing
though that I can't let go because I
have to hear the separate story why was
your brain skin disappointing oh because
it you know I looked at my brain I was
thinking my brain would be special some
kind it looks like every other brain I'd
seen like I couldn't pick my own brain
out of a lineup I mean it's sort of
actually disappointing it's it's it's
humbling you know like the idea that
here's the here's my yeah I got this
brain in my head alright and leaving
aside the leaving aside the the thorny
issue of where does the brain end and
the mind begin or vice versa
my brain is of is is largely responsible
for Who I am
and yet when I see a picture of it it's
completely unremarkable and looks like
every other brain that's being scanned
that day
there's something kind of weird and
humbling about that disappointing - I
don't know I was expecting my brain
would be cooler or something like that
you know looking back at all of your
books do you find any commonalities or
patterns and I mean we can also force
all sorts of spurious correlations but
looking at the books that seem to
struck a nerve and those that for
whatever reason didn't perform up to
your hopes yeah I you know I don't know
I mean I think that I think that when it
comes to actual performance of things
like how well a book does that's
something that's not fully I mean you
know this I mean sure anyway this that's
not something that's fully in our
control and and I'm and I'm actually you
know I'm actually more or less okay on
that I mean it's it's disappointing when
something doesn't do as well as you want
but to me my criteria my criterion is
did I write the best book I possibly
could write and once you put it out
there there's so many other variables
you just don't know whether it's gonna
take or whether it's not gonna whether
it's not going to take so I mean I wrote
a book you know my very first book was a
book called free agent nation that was
not a monumental that did okay but it
was not a monumental hit it should have
been because I think I was right but for
whatever reason I think it came out like
I think I I think just came out at the
wrong I think it came out at the wrong
time I'm sure to come out slightly
earlier and so so on that so said to me
the you know how well a book uh that's
there's so much randomness in that I'm
not I try not to lose any sleep over it
in terms of actual you know is there a
through-line among all the books that's
an interesting question and I can say
from the creation point of view there is
absolutely not a through-line uh-huh
there is no intentional through line
through these concepts through these
kinds of books it's not as if I have
mapped out somewhere on a white board
here in pink ink world headquarters in
Washington I see this like grand scheme
to create the pink in a certain fashion
in a certain time table with certain
things covered like that far from it I
just go from one thing to another I just
like figure out what I'm gonna do next
and as you know Tim I mean writing a
book is so difficult it's so hard it's
so time-consuming that if you're not in
love with the idea if you don't love
working on it you're gonna it's gonna be
miserable for you so so I just pick the
next topic based on what I'm really
interested in and one of what I want to
spend a couple of years you know a few
years working on
so I think it's possible that people can
detect it through lime that readers
could detect it through a line maybe
they're seeing something that I'm not
but if there's a through line it's
visible only retrospectively it's not
something that was intentional what was
speaking of difficulty and writing
process what if there is a if you had to
pick one what has been the most
difficult book for you to write and why
I think was this I think it was the last
one the last book that I wrote believe
it or not he would think it would get
easier over time but it didn't so this
last book when about science Tommy that
was the most difficult book to write
partly because I went to I went into
that book with so I wouldn't I started
writing a whole new mind having done the
reefs that done some research and saying
hey I think there's something going on
here like I think we're moving to this
world you know and sort of I had a
theory of the case with drive I had a
book about motivation I had looked at a
lot of the research in motivation I said
well wait a second people are missing
like a huge story here with when I went
in totally with questions rather than
with any kind of theory of the case I
basically said hey I'm making all kinds
of Tommy decisions in my own life I'm
making them in a totally half-assed way
I'd like to make them in a better way
could somebody please give me some
guidance and I started looking around
for guidance and it didn't exist and
then I started looking at the research
and I realized that across all of these
domains of research literally dozens and
dozens you from from the hard sciences
of molecular biology to endocrinology to
the social sciences of economics and
social psychology to many many domains
these scholars are asking very very
similar questions what's the effective
time of day on what we do and how we do
it how do beginnings affect us how to
midpoints affect us out of endings
affect us and so I went in saying wow
how do I make better timing decisions
myself but I didn't have a theory of the
case and so the volume of research for
this one was so monumental there are so
many studies out there and there were so
many different in so many different
fields and fields that like molecular
biology is not a subject that is at my
fingertips alright I had I spent so much
time I mean I basically would read those
papers I would read them through and I
would write down all the words
I didn't know the meaning of and then I
would look up those words and then I
would read it again and I would read it
a third time it's a very painstaking and
then also because they didn't have a
theory of the case I just had questions
rather than even kind of skeleton or a
shape of what I wanted to write I had to
figure that out so I probably did I
don't know seventeen eighteen different
outlines of that of that book so that
was that way you know you would think it
would get easier but it actually got
hard it would actually got harder
eighteen outlines what - what do what
what would such an outline look like how
long is it what's a format involved when
I say an outline its relative relatively
short just like one or two pages
nothing nothing too comprehensive I
guess outline is outline is is outline
is well it's partly the right warbird
because I'm a firm believer when it
comes to speeches and when it comes to
books I'm a firm believer in structure
and shape I think that those are what
makes some things work I think it's true
/ television shows I think it's true for
podcasts I think that structure I think
that structure and shape are very
important all right
no see here's the thing Tim I think your
podcast they don't necessarily have a
structure but they have a shape there's
no question they have a shape all right
and so it's you know it's just it's a
difference between oh we can have you're
gonna have sculptures beautiful
sculptures that have right angles and
you can have other beautiful sculptures
like a Henry Moore sculpture that has no
right angles at all but it has a
distinct and memorable and identifiable
shape right so so but I'm a big believer
in in in structure and shape and so what
I'm doing there is that that's basically
just my search for how do you organize
the ideas and what's the shape or the
structure of the final product going to
be because once I see the shape I can do
a lot better work but for this other
book you know it's like like I'm reading
through 700 Studies on all this kinds of
stuff and I'm like good god how do I
even make sense of this what do I put
where I started thinking about
organizing it do I organize this book
about timing do I organize it
basically the way that we organize time
so do I write about you know the hour
the day the week the week the month the
year the lifetime and that's a really
bad way to do it but I ended up why is
why is that bad how did you decide that
was a bad approach because for a couple
of reasons number one the material
didn't organize itself cleanly in that
way number two
that's that struck me more as a like a
handbook like a Farmers Almanac rather
than an intelligent book of science
journalism with takeaways and more
important that's not a book I would want
to read and you know and so so I so I
abandoned that but I did it but did I
really abandon it because I actually
ended up writing a whole chapter in this
book about the day so I ended up
cleaving off some of that and keeping it
for in keeping it for for other things
and so so it took me a long time to it
took me a long time to find the shape
and the way I find the shape as I
basically write it down on either what I
call big ass stickies is giant post-it
notes or or on a whiteboard that I have
in my office but I went through many
many many iterations and on that I have
a somewhat social view of that and that
what I'll do is I'll run it past people
to see what they think and say hey what
do you think if I organize the book that
way does that make any sense or or what
about that doesn't make sense or what am
I missing here what's the weak spot
there but it took me a long time - it
took me a long time to find the shape of
of this book that coupled with the fact
that the the amount of research was so
massive it was it was actually it was
actually it was actually the hardest
book I've had to write well you're doing
the research as you're writing the book
right in in effect it sounds like
because you're coming into it with
questions but then you're having to yeah
digest all of the information that might
lead or might not lead to answers while
you're writing it yeah exact exactly and
that's hard to write exactly you're so
right about that that's hard to do - and
a lot of people I mean you know as a
writer it's it's
it's it's it's messier than that there's
this notion that I'm gonna do my
research and then when my research is
done I'm gonna do my writing all right
yeah and so it never works out but but
when you have more questions and you
have when you don't know the shape yet
and you how you still have a lot of
questions what happens is I'm gonna do
the research now I'm gonna try to write
down something about it
crap you know what now that I write it I
realize I'm missing a whole thing here
and I got to do more research so let me
go back and do that so it's less of this
kind of you know you know happy march
from you know happy jumped from here's
I'm gonna go from this lily pad to that
lily pad and happily jump from each one
to another like a delighted frog there's
a lot of task switching I that's exactly
why the 4-hour chef for me was also by
far the most difficult book among other
reasons to write is that I came into it
intending to try all these experiments
ask all these questions and write the
book somewhat chronologically as I'm
getting answers and that was a very
punishing way to approach things but to
look at the content so going past the
structure and looking at the the content
findings of when I was looking at an NPR
interview that you did and teasing out
some potential ways that I could apply
the content from this book into my own
life and I'm gonna read a quote you can
feel free to correct it but this is this
is what I have as one very clear example
and I'd love to basically I'm gonna ask
you what types of decisions have
triggered three or easy ways that people
can think about making changes related
to timing so here's one then I'm gonna
I'm gonna truncate it a little bit but
quote in a lot of this research and big
data you see systematically poor
performance and healthcare settings in
the afternoon example the incidence of
hand-washing inside of hospitals
dramatically drops in the afternoon and
that seems like a bad thing to me my
voice yours you look at colonoscopies
and Dasgupta's find half as many polyps
and colonoscopies in afternoon exams
versus morning exams even with the same
population doctors are more likely to
prescribe unnecessary antibiotics in the
afternoon
compared to the morning and this seems
this is very very actionable right if we
are to trust the data if the patterns if
the correlations hold then you are
certainly better off it would seem if
you're if you want to miss Krita gate
I'm not sure that was English risk
mitigate I think I swapped the first two
letters that's that has a fancy
psychological term it's called it's
called in linguistic a tip of this lung
but yeah exactly and you you might come
back to your undergrad and linguistics
but what are other examples related to
the win the timing oh my god that people
can might be able to implement oh my
gosh there's so much stuff I mean the
good news about that is that when I did
finally wrestle the research to the
ground and figure out how to structure
it it yielded so many great great
takeaways for readers so so so take a
step back what we know from a mountain
of research took me a while to figure
this out was that we tend to move
through the day in three stages a peak a
trough a recovery
peak trough recovery now most of us move
through the day in that order people who
are night owls people who have an
evening chrono type they move through
the day in the reverse order recovery
trough peak but what we know is that we
know a few things about human
performance over the course of a day the
most important thing and this is a this
I wish somebody had told me this before
I was fifty rather than once I was fifty
all right is that our cognitive
abilities do not remain the same
throughout the day our cognitive
abilities change during the day and they
can change in some dramatic ways and
they can change at predict a change in
predictable ways but how we perform
depends on what we're doing right so
what we know at the peak which again for
most of us is the morning for night
hours it's later in the day what we know
about the peak is that the peak is when
we are most vigilant and what does
vigilance made vigilance means we're
able to bat away distractions and so
when we're vigilant and can bat away
distractions that makes it the best time
for analytic work work that requires
heads down focus writing a report
analyzing data
that kind of works there's no that piles
of research tell us that we should be
doing our analytic work during the peak
right the trough that's the early
afternoon and early to mid afternoon as
you mentioned from the data on on
healthcare a lot of bad stuff happened
that I mean you have standardized test
scores for students go down in the
afternoon you have if you look at auto
accidents once you control four cars on
the road obviously they're gonna be more
accidents when the more cars on the road
but once you control for that the most
dangerous time to drive is 4 to 6 a.m.
the second most dangerous time is 2 to 4
p.m.
during that midday trough we should be
doing more of our administrative work we
should be answering our routine emails
we should I mean you talk you've talked
in the past time about batching we
should be batching our routine emails
and answering them during the trough we
should be filling out our TPS report we
should be filling out our expense report
whatever that kind of stuff that we have
to do during the course of the day that
doesn't require a lot of major cognitive
power now the recovery period again
because this peak trough recovery is a
pattern of mood that also is a pattern
of performance the recovery period is
actually really really interesting
during the recovery period we have
elevated mood our mood is better than
during the trough but we're less
vigilant than during the peak and so
it's really important to think about
that combo platter here that is you have
higher mood but less vigilance that
makes it a good time for things like
brainstorming for for things like
insight work where if you're too locked
down and focused you're not going to be
that creative and so that that degree of
looseness coupled with the elevated mood
makes that recovery stage better for
what are called insight problems
brainstorming things that require
iteration and so what we see is that if
you if we recognize that our cognitive
abilities don't stay the same over the
course of a day that they change in
predictable ways and that what we do
that when we do something depends on
what we're doing we should be moving our
analytic work to the peak our
administrative work to the try
and our insight and creative work to the
recovery and it's that simple and what
the research tells us also is this I
mean is that time of day explains about
20% of the variance in how people
perform on cognitive tasks so if you
think about that that's a big deal like
we can explain the very like if fret you
know if we have two people you know
Maria and Sally and they perform
differently on cognitive tasks how do we
explain that all right we say how do we
explain that variance in how people
perform you know Maria Sally and and you
know eighteen thousand other people
perform on cognitive tasks we say oh
some people are smarter than other
people
some people are more conscientious than
other people some people have more
social advantage in other people but
what the researcher is telling us that
20% of that variance is time of day and
so and so so what we should be doing is
and what we're not doing is we should be
making our when decisions in a strategic
way rather than in the lazy haphazard
way with which we tend to make our wind
decisions and so and you see this most
glaringly and this is my rant of the of
the of the year is you see this most
glaringly with meetings in organizations
when we schedule meetings and
organizations the only criterion we use
is availability that's it
who's available we don't say what kind
of meeting is this this is a meeting
where people have to be analytical what
kind of meeting is this is this about
travel voucher policies what kind of
meeting is this are we brainstorming
who's gonna be there are they gonna be
morning people are they gonna be
intermediate people are gonna be evening
people we don't even ask those questions
we just say who's available and it's
causing it's it's one of the easiest
things organization related to fix and
it's something that at the unit of one
individuals can be a lot more systematic
and intentional about moving the right
work into the right time slots what what
time of day do you generally wake up
personally I I wake up a little after
7:00 and what is what is the first two
hours of your day look like do you do
you have particular any particular
routines can you walk us through with
that I don't
I don't have the the detailed routines
that that you have that you've written
about that you actually have
experimented with and you know things
like like journaling and meditation or
anything like that here's what I do I
wake up alright I I take a shower a
shower helps me wake up so I take a
shower I go downstairs and I feel better
if I see a member of my family so
whoever happens to be awake I might I
have two kids in college now so I don't
see them but I have another kid who
still are still around so I see him I
see my wife and I like to have some
protein for breakfast if that's a ritual
and caffeine protein and caffeine oh my
it's my preferred right what's your
go-to protein you know what I am I
probably eat more hard-boiled eggs than
almost any other person in America I I'm
keeping the hard-boiled egg industry in
business
I think I'm single-handedly responsible
for the advent of hard-boiled eggs for
sale and individually wrapped packages
in airports because once they once they
introduce that I bought them all and
they go oh my god there's such demand
for these hard-boiled eggs so I was
actually same time I what I eat so many
eggs is ridiculous
so so I don't have a cholesterol problem
fortunately so so hard-boiled eggs or or
peanut butter and then what I do is when
I'm in my writing day and this is
actually something I did better having
read this book when I went on writing
days I will go to my office which again
is behind my house and I will not bring
my phone with me I will not turn on my
email and I will give myself a quota and
that quota is usually is a word count so
call it 700 words I'm a fairly slow
writer so you got these people out there
here all right 3,000 word today and it's
like I don't think I've ever done that
and so very very slow I'm proud I may be
slower than you or even yeah well here's
the thing I'm slow and basically I'm
basically slow in every in every domain
of my life
I'm like just such a dis I'm a slow
runner I'm a slow reader I'm a slow
writer I like I really heavily
scrutinized my 23andme report to see if
I had some kind of like tortoise gene in
me somewhere that's somehow like one of
my ancestors and Latvia somehow made it
with a tortoise at some point and so and
so and so so but what I will do though
is I will come in and give myself that
quota and I won't do anything until I
hit that number and then I'm free to do
other kinds of things and then what I'll
do is I always I'll have a lunch and
then I will I like to do I have done a
good job especially after like this this
book changed the way that I organized my
day because I do my analytic work better
in the morning so this book this book
compelled me to clear out my mornings to
do that analytic work which for me is
writing I stuff the administrative stuff
often to the to the to the midday and
then batched emails and that kind of
garbage and then I like to do interviews
especially when I'm interviewing like
for book interviews I like to do those
later in the day because I'm a little
bit more I like the interviews to be a
little bit more freewheeling I'm not
doing I'm not an investigative reporter
I'm not conducting a deposition I just
you know want to hear people's stories
and what they think about stuff and so
you know I'm avoiding the Yale Law and
Policy Review vol 8 number 2 1990 no you
know so I want that to be a little bit
more iterative and then I'll and then I
actually end up exercising later I end
up realizing later in the day and in the
early evening cuz I find that that works
best for me you said on a writing day
when you were on book deadline
how many what is your week weekly
structure tend to look like do you do
you is everyday a writing day I'm also
I'm also a momentum player so so for me
writing everyday is hugely important
when I'm when I'm working on a when I'm
working on a when I'm working on a book
or working on web article so I try to do
that I try to do that every single
like like seven days a week and do you
have do you have set periods of time
between books do you decide in advance
I'm gonna take X period of time until I
investigate another book what is what is
your macro planning look like macro
planning boy my macro planning is
neither macro nor planned I think that
needs to be on a motivational calendar
somewhere another way if that question
sucks which it might because it's also
making a bunch of assumptions how do you
decide when to take on new projects or
new books if that's a better question I
sort of go in I sort of go in cycles so
I'm actually heading to that cycle right
now so I spent a lot of time writing
this book and try to make it as good as
good a book as I can in terms of
actually spreading the word about it I
try to do that with you know give the
cliche not leaving anything on the
sidelines and doing everything I
possibly can being everywhere Thank You
tea jig about at all trying new stuff
trying cool stuff trying to get some
momentum behind behind the book and then
you know when that and when that sort of
white-hot center dissipates and the book
we hope has some momentum of its own
then I'll go back and figure out the
next project whatever that project might
be and the way I do that is I know this
will shock you Tim in a slow laborious
way what I do is is I um I have I'm a
sort of a I use giving my mechanisms
here so I use a balloon or not I use a
lot of paper folders and I have a label
er I use paper folders and a label er to
label my folders because I was like a
getting things done guy before I get
anything he's done was cool the I met I
met David Allen like in 1997 and you
know I bought a label er like shortly
after that I was gonna ask if he's if
he's sending you your customer in you
know 5% royalties for your
the brainpower you're like the guy who
invented rollerblades or the gal you
know forty years before they became cool
oh yeah no no I I'm a I'm a GTV devotee
I'm not I'm not hardcore I'm not like
you know Orthodox but I'm not I'm not
I'm not reformed either I'm sort of like
in the middle and so so so anyway I have
these paper files with labels and so
when I read stuff or make notes of
myself I throw stuff in those those
files I use Evernote and I you also use
Dropbox and I just throw ideas in there
and then what I do is every six months
or so I go through those ideas of like
hey this would be a cool television show
to do and hey this would be a cool
article all right hey this would be a
cool book to write and as I look at
those ideas maybe revisiting them every
six months or so I realize that most of
them are just god-awful ideas one of my
beliefs about the human brain is that
our creativity is that in order to have
good ideas you have to have a lot of
ideas and so I have a lot of bad ideas
which i think is the only way for me to
surface any decent ideas so I'll revisit
those ideas and then when it comes in a
call and what often happens when I call
is that a few ideas end up just staying
there over and over again every six
months cycle and then when it's I get to
this point now I will go back to all of
those files and look more carefully and
say hey I sort of have in my mind's eye
right now three possible projects and
and so I'll more heavily vet those
projects read a lot more talk to people
bounce them bounce ideas off of people
and and I like bouncing ideas some
people about which more at a moment and
and then when it comes time to write a
book I will actually write a book
proposal even if I have the deal already
done so if like I have a two book deal
like I have to I have to write another
book but I'll still write a proposal for
this next book maybe forty page proposal
which allows me to figure out is there
there there is this something I really
want to work on you know I think I think
a lot of things sound really good when
you're just shooting the breeze
they sound less good if you have to say
can I can I explain this can I explain
this idea who's gonna buy it
why it's cool why its original why no
one else is doing it can I explain that
in a coherent written document that's a
tougher order and so not everything
blends itself with that and I will
bounce ideas out of people so I Oh No so
actually it's funny you mentioned Kevin
at the beginning of the show I had this
one idea where I went out and I went to
I made the pilgrimage to what is it
would call this town Pacifica Pacifica
yeah and made the pilgrimage to Kevin's
house and said I got an idea I want to
run past you for a book and Kevin was
one of the people who said that's not a
very good idea
and unfortunately he was not the only
one who said that and more unfortunately
an depending on how you look at I mean
if you see yeah no no actually
fortunately you're right fortunately he
was he was not the only one who said
that so I abandoned I and actually ended
up abandoning that idea in part because
he was another brick in the wall of
people saying no no no let's pause there
for a quick second do you mind sharing
I don't think Kevin would care at all
what he or other people made is
arguments against you pursuing this idea
and you can tell us what the idea was
where you can yeah would it be I'm gonna
be I'm gonna be skittish about the idea
but let's just say it had to do with
morality all right I wanted to write a
book dealing with morality and and Kevin
who is a person of religious faith who
you know is extraordinarily well-read
and among people who are very well-read
and very intelligent there are I think
there are a dearth of people who have
strong religious faith just an
observation it's not like a judgment one
way or the other right and so I thought
he was just an especially good person to
run this idea past and and I guess he
and others the theory of theory the case
that I had he and others had two
criticism and they are not insignificant
criticisms ten the first criticism was
you're wrong all right to begin with
you're wrong all right and the second
part the second criticism was you're
right but it's not interesting
those are pretty like that's those are
like those are significant critiques
right so so so that's a so that's how I
so that's that's that's generally that's
generally how I do things when I come up
with this idea for when it was an idea
that was kicking around there and one of
the one of the ways that I knew it was a
good idea were two things number one is
that when I was writing the propose when
I first of all look at the research and
I found myself wanting to do more
research which is always a good sign
like holy crap is that true
well what about poverty ba and I go look
at ba ba ba oh my god Bobby Boston you
know and so I found myself wanting to do
more research that was one thing and
then when I started writing the proposal
for that it was like for me it doesn't
happen very often but there are portions
of it that we're just like butter I
could just explain it so clearly like
here's what I'm gonna try to find out
and here's why it matters and it was
like it was like that you know that
that's seen in in Jerry Maguire where he
writes all night and I'm taking the
goldfish - the goldfish I was and I was
doing handstands against the wall and
everything like that so there and that's
um that sometimes that sometimes I good
that sometimes a good sign
I think it's yep that that lack of or
overabundance of energy I think is
undervalued how much the project
actually gives you more go to tank and I
think the big you know here's the thing
I think a lot of writers I think a lot
of people who come out as journalists
and before I started writing books you
know I post speech writing sort of sort
of as a you know in even the deferred
time those writing books I did a lot of
magazine articles 11:11 magazine writing
long-form magazine writing which I which
I like and I found a lot of journalists
who would write an article the article
would do well and they would get a book
offer and they would do they would they
would not pop they were not properly
vetted about whether they want it is
there a lot of ideas that you you know
you want to go out under a few dates
with but they're very few ideas that you
want to go steady with let alone marry
and have kids and I think that books are
basically you're marrying and having
kids yeah and that's a very very very
high bar there are there are a lot of
great articles that should stay articles
and make all my very mediocre books and
you know be potentially I suppose not
vice-versa is very rare that you go in
the opposite direction but oh that's so
I mean it's so III read I read I want to
say the name if I read one of those this
I mean send it from your blurb I read
one of those this weekend where somebody
had an article it did really well they
got a book deal they turned it into a
book and it's like okay you know what
this argh this thing has so much more
impact as an article rather than as a
book right so what I dig in a little bit
on this tickler file that you review
every six months yeah because yeah one
of the most frequent questions I am
asked is how do you pick projects how do
you vet projects and you mentioned
revisiting every six months with a few
mundane questions within Evernote do you
have a specific notebook that is tickler
file or something like that how do you
keep track of all of these ideas I I I
can actually look that up right now I
could what I do is I categorize them so
so why I have so what I have is I have a
giant file called misc all right
it's like shards okay but then I'll go
through that and say wait us I only
think of an example here wait a wait a
second I
Wow I I'm collecting a lot of articles
about here's a book I'm not gonna could
be interesting at one point if they've
got so much you write a book about
courage all right like what about
courage what do we know about courage
all right I'm not gonna do that if one
of your listeners wants to go out and do
it god bless you I think it could be
really interesting so I could go into
the mist file and say ooh the mist
notebook I guess that it's called is
what do we know about courage and I said
good in the mist notebook and I say wow
there I got a lot of articles about
courage what that's gonna they're gonna
that's going to birth a separ
notebook on courage and then it
organized it that way so I'll have I'll
have notebooks of misc and I'll have
notebooks of particular ideas that
that's that I have that end up being
fuller because it's like oh this this
one has stuck around for a little bit
longer than others and you mentioned
during these reviews you might say oh
here's that cool idea for this a cool
idea for that oh this could be really
interesting that could be really
interesting I would imagine
even after the the second glance and
noticing that some of these ideas are
coyote ugly and you're like holy [ __ ] I
did I think that was a good idea even
after removing the Flies in the soup you
still you still I got ya you still you
still have way you could drown under the
weight of these kind of cool ideas you
have many things that could be
interesting how do you then what are the
parameters or thought processes
questions anything that help you to get
down to the three finalists okay so so
what are we so it would be what it's
really like what would I want to spend a
couple of years on and so if I really
sort of like it like maybe courage would
be an example that's like I'm sort of
interested in that but it'd be like I
would I would rather read a good book
about courage than write a book about
courage I'm serious it's like and so
when you when you go face to face with
that and you start saying do I really
want to do this then I think your your
soul at some level tells you hey this is
that you're into this you're not you're
not so you're not so into that and so
that I think that's the I think that's
the initial cut but it's also the one
reason why I so to get to the three
final this is actually really kind of
intuitive and in a way and and there's
no magic number to three it could be
four you know and and and so but this is
one reason why I will write book
proposals
because it just forces me to it forces
me to reckon with the idea and actually
like make it real and and there's this
principle that I learned in college at a
writing course in college and I actually
ended up giving a commencement speech
around this idea I'll spare you that for
now but the idea was the idea was follow
it was a revelation to me when I was
whatever 21 years old so I had this so
as his writing as his essay writing
course sure higher-level essay writing
course and I had a draft of an essay or
something like that I went into the
professor his name is Charlie you are
not be still I went to Northwestern he
still teaches at Northwestern and so
Charlie gave me some feedback and I said
I was like all insistent okay I can fix
this I can move this part over here
maybe I'd do another piece over here
maybe I knew another piece over here and
he's like no no no no Dan that's not
your problem here the problem is that
you don't know what you think that's
that's what this essay sucks this draft
is yeah you don't know what you don't
know what you think he didn't say sucks
but that's why this essay that's why
this essay that's why this says he
stinks and then he said something to me
and I and I don't want to I don't want
it to sound glorified or sound like
something that is confess when of music
will come up behind me in this but what
he said he said but it's words I've
never forgotten truly he said sometimes
you have to write to figure it out
sometimes you have to write to figure it
out and that was a revelation to me
because at the time I was in this mode
very kind of traditional schooling mode
we're sort of like we were talking about
before you do your research then you're
right you make your outline then you
write and what he was saying to me is
that you know the real writers are it's
more dynamic than that sometimes you
have to write to figure it out and that
was transformative for me and so that
sort of gave me permission to say oh I
don't know it like I can change my mind
and midway writing something I can start
writing without knowing fully exactly
what it is I'm going to say and to me
that's the that's that's why I write
book proposals is that I write to figure
it out and a lot of times what I figure
out is this is not a book or this is not
a book I want to write so I had this one
moment not meant a few years ago where
while ago no actually 10 years ago even
more where my my I sent it was like
winner like late second half of December
and I asked I said to my wife and and I
said once you just take our guys or kids
three kids just go see your parents just
go for a week right or two weeks or
something like they're gonna go and like
I just I got to get a book proposal done
I just I'm distracted if they if you
guys when you guys were my family leaves
it's like I live like an animal you know
I mean I guess I got like a raccoon that
got into the house no truly I mean it is
raccoon like and that I literally eat
out of containers you know so like my
family leaves I eat out of containers
don't shave and basically work around
the clock except for a few ESPN breaks
that's basically what I do when my
family is gone and so I will so I so I
started so I said I'm gonna write a
proposal for this next book and after
about seven or eight days I called
Jessica at her parents house I say hey I
got some good news and some bad news the
good news is that you can come home now
the bad news is that I realized this is
not a book hey but it was only writing
to figure out that allowed me to do that
so I actually wrote basically one and a
half proposals before writing the wind
proposal because I had a couple ideas
and I said okay this is sort of
interesting but let me write to figure
it out and what I realized and in you
know two very important things one it's
not a book maybe it's an article or two
it's not a book that I want to write
there's there's a few things racoon
behavior aside that I want to follow up
on the first is just to highlight
something for people listening and that
is how liberating it is to think about
writing as something you do not when you
have your ideas ready but something you
do to figure out your ideas absolutely
because it wait you when did you learn
that I it's been I would say reiterated
it's something that is easy to forget
particularly if you have or something
that you will willfully forget if you
have a perfectionist streak
and a penchant for procrastination so if
you want to wait until all your Ducks
are in a row so you can go to the
debutante ball pristine and blow
everybody socks off it's easy to forget
this but the sounds like you know the
cat came back the very next day I don't
think of the song but Kevin Kelly's too
in Kent his name again he is he
emphasizes to me he's such a prolific
writer and emphasized this to me a
number of years ago and I want to say it
goes back probably to McPhee who is also
much like you obsessed with structure
and if there's a book I think it's
called draft number four yeah just came
out it has some some really fascinating
explorations of this for those people
who really want to get into the weeds
they'll also do it graphically he'll
draw out yeah hiya grams of what the
structure looks like which appeals to me
but trying to stay on track here I would
say Kevin is the most well you are the
most recent person but a number of years
ago Kevin emphasized that to me and
probably before that make fee so it's
it's really liberating number one to
embrace that even if you're not fully
convinced it's the case and I also want
to give a little bit of context for
people who may not be familiar with book
proposals so book proposals in the world
of nonfiction books well I suppose I
should take a further step back and say
in the world of nonfiction so if you're
in novels and fiction are totally
different in many cases you need to you
need to finish that puppy before anyone
but will always tell you if your baby is
ugly or not which is has to be
terrifying it must be in in nonfiction
you create a book proposal before you
write your book and the book proposal
and feel free to interject at any point
but the book proposal is in effect a
business plan and an overview slash
executive summary for your book and
there's there's a lot you find with the
best book proposals and the best startup
pitches which take the form of a deck
say a PowerPoint or something like that
very often there
exceptionally similar the the
ingredients that make a good startup
pitch and the ingredients to make a good
book proposal are very similar but that
that is and I'd love to actually know
what the structure of your book
proposals look like I mean I know what
ingredients I would potentially include
in a book proposal
what is the table of contents look like
for one of your book proposals yeah I'd
have to go back and look I think they
vary a little bit but they probably have
some core design elements one of them is
in it's questions that I want to ask
myself which is what is this book what's
it about okay pretty simple it's a
pretty simple question why this is but I
think the more important question is why
does it why does it feel a need that
hasn't been filled yet which is
basically very similar I use the same
business plan analogy that you do on
boat proposals but it's sort of like a
business like why why is it providing a
what why is it filling a need that it
hasn't otherwise been met like like
we're like basically if you draw a map
at the marketplace what part of the
marketplace of ideas is this is this is
cover that hasn't been covered all right
is it this you know a so that so it's
it's sort you know and I don't even mean
it in my sometimes we'll use the high
concept I sometimes will use the high
concept pitch of its X meets Y which I
actually think is actually a very useful
heuristic and figuring out idea so for
instance I pitched a whole new mind as
future shock meets seven Habits of
Highly Effective People which I thought
it was pretty good pitch and so very
common in pitching films also just yeah
it's really it's a heuristic and it
basically to me it says if you think
about a map of the territory if you
think about a map of ideas out there why
is no one over here on this part of the
map all right
like show me show me where show me
she'll be wearing the map your idea is
all right and let's make sure that
someone hasn't gotten there first and
then tell me why someone has it gone
there first what
they miss it and so in the case of when
for instance say well the reason they're
missing is everybody thinks science that
timing is an art but it's actually
science oh okay got it that's why no one
it's there and it's always talked about
what's it about where does it fit into
the marketplace of ideas why is it
original and this is also really
important who is it for
all right and and the big mistake that
that everybody writing a book and if
there's one takeaway from this
conversation for prospective writers out
there it's this the mistake that writers
make and I think business people make
too and they're in their pitches is when
they say who's it for who's the audience
who's the customer they always want to
say everybody and it's not it's never
everybody all right and and what I try
to do if I have included a section of
who is who is not going to buy that book
like I will have a year the section on
who isn't the customer right I was not
who is not going to buy this book
because I think that that's the only way
to think carefully about because books
are not a mass medium and even media
products in general are no longer mass
medium mass media they're no longer mass
and it's like who is and so I'll have
bullets and they're saying who is not
going to buy this book and and that and
and and that helps and that helps to
find the audience to and also I try to
you know that's all but you know that's
really all that it is but if you know
what the book is about where it fits
into the marketplace of ideas why it's
different from anything else that that
came before it and why and who's and who
it's for I think those components are
really essential but that fourth
component is and I say this to writer is
to like I write you tell me who the book
is not for tell me who's not gonna buy
this book and people have a hard time
saying well everybody will buy this book
somebody pitch to me an idea somebody
came to me once with an idea of a book
about someone who's give me asking your
advice on it there was a book about I
hope I don't I don't I think the book
might have gotten published
I don't reveal the name it was a book
about the history of yoga in America
alright the history or maybe the history
of you yeah I think was a history of
yoga
it's like okay that's that's cool so I
think a lot of people who do yoga might
be interested in that and she said well
I think people who don't do yoga are
gonna be interested in this and I said
no they're not like people who don't do
yoga don't care about the history load
of people in America who do yoga like
that's a pretty good audience right
there but don't tell me every you know
what I mean and so you know you know so
so for me it's like you know for me it's
like like my books like okay I know that
the the like this book about the site
that this book about the science of
timing I know that certain people in my
neighborhood in Northwest Washington DC
who read or of a certain age and read
only literary fiction and 700 page
biographies of founding fathers they're
not going to read this book they're not
going to read they might be my neighbors
they're not gonna read one of my books
and so I think that's really really
important about who is the book not for
well it's also an indicator of focus and
logical / rational thinking in a sense
right because if you're afraid it's just
a digress for a minute but if you're in
the world of investing where I spent a
long time with early-stage startups
seventeen years or so if if they say
everyone is my customer there is a very
real risk that if you give them X number
of dollars you give them a million
dollars that they could be developing
Dropbox for say early tech adopters and
the first wave then they they need to
get from zero to ten thousand users and
if there is a 80% off deal for something
like shopping mall circulars or
something that they would jump on that
and piss away all their money and
certainly I think books a lot of books
fail this is true presentations to from
too much miscellaneous information not
too little if that makes any sense
absolutely it's it's a matter of it's
it's it's really just a matter of it's
really just a matter of focus and I
going back to
speech thing I mean one of the one of
the pieces of advice the extent that
anybody ever asked me for advice I'm
giving some giving speeches and whatnot
is you know and it sounds a little like
a it sounds like a Zen Cohen ish sort of
phrase but basically my point is say
something important rather than say
important things and like I find a lot
of times people say something important
rather than say important things because
I think a lot of times people like that
sort of stuff within the skin all the
things they've found out all the things
that they know and they end up not
saying anything important and so you
know yeah so so that's that's the reason
for do it that's so enter you get the
idea
ya know it is and there are so many
comparable examples if for instance you
look for this this vetting of ideas by
putting together a short synopsis of
some time yeah and and there's one
example for instance and I believe this
is true I've certainly heard it and read
about it a few times and I know a fair
number of people who work at Amazon but
they'd have to confirm I think Ian
McAlister who used to at least be a
general manager in Amazon talked about
this is working backwards and for oh
yeah for new initiatives the product
manager who would be in charge of
developing say a new product has to
write an internal press release which
announces the finished product right so
that and and that has to focus on
effectively exactly what with what you
said and I'm quoting here from a medium
piece but quotes centered around the
customer problem how current solutions
internal or external fail and how the
new product will blow away existing
solutions and it's the same thing it's
the same thing if you can't write that
press release like how on earth are you
going to navigate the decision tree of
getting to a product that finds its feet
I mean it could be very different
difficult not to say you don't iterate
but it's it's a good I it's a good
filter through which you can at least
catch the detritus that shouldn't make
it to step 2 oh man I
to say I am your hallelujah chorus' on
that press release technique I've
literally done that working with working
I think it's helpful for like nonprofit
groups that I'm involved in so a
non-profit group wants to do a big
project but they're all over the place
they don't know exactly what they want
to do and I literally did this I said
I'll tell you what here's what I think
the project is let me write a press
release from two years from now and
they'll send it around and it ended up
being
I got the idea from Amazon - and it
ended up being this thing that was
really really focused so the blabbity
blah group announced today that it was
doing babidi blabbity blabbity blah and
it's like you know and then if you had
quotes and things in it and it ended up
being this this focal point on for the
whole organization on what are we
actually trying to accomplish here so
i'm a i-i-i-i second that emotion
they're not and just to return to
another thing you said which i'll
paraphrase here as if everyone's our
customer no one's your customer yeah
another filter that or question that i
use or have used i'm not really in the
startup game anymore but have used a lot
with startups because they'll ask me to
review say a landing page and look at
copy and messaging and so on and before
I will review it
because I'll if with no further
information I have to review it based on
my pair of eyes and my perspective and
my particular problems I can try to
empathize and put myself in other
people's shoes but I have to know whose
shoes to put myself in and so I'll ask
them if you could only have a thousand
people sign up for this who would they
be and why like describe for me and this
isn't a politically correct exercise
like what is like gender race if that
matter is maybe it doesn't like where do
they live what magazines or websites do
they read what is their household income
like really get granular about what
these people have in common right like
do you want all the readers of People
magazine do you want the right 2000
people who attend Ted do you want some
time in between like really describe
that right and only once that's been
done can I actually give feedback on
modifying any of the features or copy or
messaging on a particular page
that's I mean it's it's these these
principles really transfer to a lot of
different areas well I let me ask a just
a handful of additional questions and
then maybe we can do around to some time
but the we've been talking a lot about
the decisions you've made the routines
that you have and although you're very
self-effacing I mean someone could look
at your bio and be very intimidated and
assume that you step up to the plate and
hit homeruns more often than not could
you tell us about maybe it specific if
you're open to it difficult period that
you've gone through or a down period
challenging period or failure could be
any of those things and what you did to
get back on your feet or the decisions
you made that helped you then getting
get back on firm ground if if anything
comes to mind sure sure sure there are
all kinds of things so I mean I hate to
keep going back to the I hate to keep
going back to the law school days but
but I I did leave law school after my
first year and I hated it so much that I
went to India instead and I travelled
around I traveled around India which was
incredible life-changing experience
because I was a young guy you know
whatever old it was like 25 26 years old
and hey you know at the time they
missile you know what's a while ago so
at the time India was even cheaper well
much much cheaper than it was so if
you're like a 25 year old dudes
traveling on your own with a little tiny
little bit of money in your pocket you
can make me go very very very very far
and so so at the time I guess I felt
like because I didn't do very well in my
initial foray into law school I didn't
really like it I was pretty miserable I
felt that had made a terrible decision
and I some level just tried to escape
and and the way I got back into it was
essentially saying okay if I'm gonna do
this then I'm gonna try to figure out
what are the one or two things that I
can find valuable in this experience and
try to power my way through and I guess
that's all I get that's all that I get
that's all that I I guess that's all
that I did to overcome that but I felt
pretty bad about how I didn't do very
well I didn't I didn't really like it I
thought I had made it like I thought I
had made like a ruinous decision about
about how my life was gonna go and when
I sort of kind of woke up and matured a
little bit I said okay
some people makes like bad things
actually happened to people and I think
going to India was actually helpful in
that regard too because like okay I'm
not living in a tarpaper Shack with
filthy water all right I'm just I'm not
self actualizing fast enough for a 25
year old middle class person that's not
a real problem and so I think that sort
of putting the problems in perspective
and just trying to find some some
goodness in what you're doing next and
also I just like really driving specific
lessons from these kinds of failures and
and I think that's another part that's
really important to me is it rather than
rather than simply allow like sort of
this hazy notion of what you learn I
again I'm a big believer in writing
things in and writing things down I'll
give you I'll give you a better I'll
give you a better example of that and
this is I don't want to call this like a
major failure because it's not that
that's not that significant but so I did
a TV show for National Geographic and I
worked with a TV series and I worked
with some really great people and we put
on a really freakin great show and it
didn't get picked up for a second season
and and so it was disappointing but it's
not like a massive failure it's not like
anything real like in life but at that
time what I did is I said you know I
basically created a file and said okay
here's what I learned from this
experience things that I learned from
this experience like one I like working
with really talented people they have
people who help me perform better - I
don't like to be involved in projects
that I don't have full contract creative
control over three working with people
in traditional television can be very
perilous because they're subject to all
kinds of pressures that are out of their
control and so you have this experience
where things didn't go the way you
wanted to but if you actually literally
write down lessons I think you can get
something positive out of it and was the
writing down of these lessons more of a
cathartic exercise or these would you go
back and revisit that you know what I
like like for me a lot of times what I
will do is for me it's sometimes certain
writing things down is simply the act of
writing it down is enough to solidify it
so I'll do the kind of thing where
before a talk or something like that I
will like write an outline like like
basically I know what I want to do and
then I'll take notes and write an
outline of the speech and the points I
want to hit and then I will literally
will not look at it like I sometimes
won't even bring it up with me I'll
forget to bring it up with me because
the act of the act of actually
memorializing it is really what gives it
it's it's it's goom's
this is what I don't want what I'm
trying to say in a somewhat ham-handed
way is that like when you you want to
you don't want those kinds of lessons to
be hazy too much you want to actually
what like what specific thing that I
actually derive from this and I think
that's really useful there's also a
great technique that Tina Seelig has
used Kim Sela who's that Stanford has
used where she talks about she writes a
failure resume so she has a resume of
all of her failures and then with each
one what she learned from it when would
she use something like that I mean she
keeps it for herself but she would you
know I see it's an ongoing working
document just like everything
yeah yeah ongoing working document that
basically so you can look at it and say
okay what about you know boy I made a
lot of mistakes but here's what I
learned from it and don't make the same
mistake a second time I don't mind
making mistakes what I don't like is
making the same mistake twice with the
two questions on India why India and
then second how did you decide to find
the compelling I suppose benef
of continuing with law school versus
changing course let's see you know what
I think okay it's on the second one I
think it was to risk averse to change
course fully I think that what I think
that would have been too much excuse me
too much of like a narcissist the injury
just to like leave altogether I probably
would have
I probably would have felt like an
abject failure so I don't even think
that was in the cards so on the why
India a couple reasons I had always been
fascinated by it I knew that I could get
around that that I that I the previous
summer I had been to Southern Africa and
you know and it was the first I had
never been out of the country until I
was 23 years old in urban um and so the
first time I left the country I went to
Southern Africa on a I got to raise some
money to do this front to do some
project there and maybe that was a
revelation like holy crap this world is
a lot bigger than I thought and so I
wanted to go to someplace that wasn't
you know Europe or someplace that was a
little bit different from a little bit
more different from the United States
and so India was a place that always
been fascinated by it spoke English and
it was cheap that's that's a compelling
combination for someone leaving law
school for period well when you're yeah
when you're 25 years old or however old
I was and and you have like a little
money in your pocket but you can go so
you could go so far I'm still little
money
it was unbelievable to me you know
especially if you're willing to like
sleepover like take over night trains
rather than pay for a place to stay or
you know live in these you know go to
sleep in these places where there's just
a row of beds on a on a balcony and then
mosquito nets over each one so the me
travel is one of those gifts that keeps
on giving in a sense I would put books
in that same category you yeah yeah I
great you've written a lot of books
you've read even more books besides your
own and I'll just get a segue into a
couple of short questions what what
books are there any books that you've
gifted
often to other people or people oh yeah
so they're probably books that you're I
mean I met have been books that you've
covered in this in your show here so one
of them is bird by bird by n Lamont one
of the greatest things ever I come back
to that advice so many different times
it's a saying even in the pink household
we're like we'll just say like like one
member of my family said to the other
who's struggling okay
bird by bird bird by bird and so I am a
huge and I stumbled into this book I
remember I've got I remember where I got
this next book I got it in the airport
in San Francisco in the bookstore in the
San Francisco and for some reason I
picked it up because it had this really
weird cover but one of the first
editions of the war of art by Steven
Pressfield had this kind of silvery
cover to it and I bought that book in
the I think there's a compass bookstore
in SFO just because that's kind of cool
had silver cover and it's really short I
got it it's like oh my god I can't
believe how good this book is and so I
even have a little sign on my desk here
that says beat the resistance so I've
given that book out a lot too
so Pressfield and Lamont and then man I
have to say Viktor Frankl man's search
for meaning is up there too it's less I
give it to be I've given out less but
that's a that's a hugely important book
for me yeah that's that's one of those
books I really need to reread and I
think you've you've actually spoken
about let me get this right I was about
to say animal house but that is not
right animal farm farm is one of the
greatest books ever and and how you it's
a completely different experience as a
book at different points in your life
and absolutely right and the last time I
read man's search for meaning was
probably I would say seven to ten years
ago and a lot has changed in my life in
that period of time
I think that that is worthy of a reread
and have you it sounds like you've
reread each of these books also bird by
bird the war of art man's search for
meaning yourself you've read these more
yeah yeah yeah I'm read more than one
yeah and I'm not like a chronic reader
I'm like there are some people who are
regularly they're relatively few books
that I have that I have reread but but
those that those I those I absolutely
have and once you know I had another
experience in college
only thing I remember in college are
shards of things that professors said
like basically one-liners but I had a
professor once in college who in an
American Studies course he assigned us
to read The Adventures of Huckleberry
Finn so your attic you're in college and
your professor assigned you to read a
bunch of Huckleberry Finn people are
like oh you know because like everybody
read that book in high school and and he
said something he said the following
words he says I know you've read that
book but you haven't read that book
meaning the person you are today and and
that ends up being but that ends up
being true so when I've read I read
Animal Farm at different points in my
life and had a different view on it I've
read Great Gatsby at different points in
my life I have seen them play by Death
of a Salesman before I don't know
probably seven times and each one feels
a little bit different to me I had a
completely different view of Death of a
Salesman once I became a father versus
before I became a father I had I had
another view of Death of a Salesman
before I knew about you know knew you
know had read about psychopharmacology
and mental illness and after I did and
so you know III think that that
experiences are really fascinating
animal farmers like oh it's really cool
it's about the Soviet Union in power
corrupts and blah blah blah and and and
now I read the book it's like okay this
book is basically about organizational
dysfunction this book and I who cares
whether its source about the Soviet
Union this book is about the Acme widget
corporation and how screwed up human
organizations are like this I think that
alarm should be in every organizational
behavior class in an MBA program that's
another one I need to reread not a long
book either I mean I've read that in no
no sixth grade or something I mean -
completely completely you'll see it
completely you'll see it completely
differently that's that's a great book
I've read 1984 multiple times - also a
very timely book on that front I read a
the handmade sale for the first time I'm
sort of 30 years late to it that I read
and I love that book I have a whole I'm
not joking around and if you want
validation I'll send you with fotógrafo
but I basically have a stack of books
right here that it's basically dystopia
books that includes Philip Roth the plot
against America and I gave you a butler
book Sinclair Lewis it can't happen here
another sci-fi book called Elliot by
elliott pepper calculus another one
called info mock recei by mal colder I
have a whole I'm basically I have a
whole pile of dystopian works why is
that why do you why do you understand I
want to understand that the current
moment mark more clearly so well this
might be its might be an appropriate
next question it doesn't have to be
related to what you just said but if you
could put a short message on a billboard
metaphorically speaking to get a word a
quote a question out to millions or
billions of people what might you put on
that billboard well it's interesting
because I think it is related to what
we're just talking about or maybe the
fact that you asked it in this context
made me related but one of the one of
the things that I would I would write
would be assume positive intent I would
fit very nicely on a billboard assume
positive intent because I think and I
changed my view on this Tim III i-i've
actually in some ways become I've sort
of gone the reverse like like basically
the general view is that people are
idealistic when they're young and
cynical when they're older and I've
actually become less cynical
as I've gotten older and the other thing
is basically on politics like you know
that like there's this old line in
politics like everybody dies a
Republican right you know because like
as you get older and you have something
to conserve you become more conservative
I find myself going actually out the
opposite direction as I understand more
about the more about the world but the
point is a point of all that and assume
positive intent is that I think and it
goes to our politics right now
is that a lot of times I don't you know
I just think like your default you know
this already
our default settings are so important in
any realm of our life and I think a lot
of times if your default setting is that
people have everybody you deal with has
negative intent that's gonna lead you
down one pathway there's no question
about it and and here's the thing I
don't think that's true I really my
experience as a human being is that some
people obviously have negative intent
but most people do not most people
actually have positive intent so my view
is that if you assume positive intent on
the part of others and let them disprove
that that's a better way to go than to
assume negative intent and say I'm going
to assume that you have negative intent
tim ferriss until you prove that you
actually have positive intent I think
just doing the reverse during the
reverse is better it's like assume
positive intent that's it I don't I'm
not Pollyanna here I don't think
everybody has positive but I think most
people do and if you just just make that
your default setting you're gonna have
better interactions with people you're
gonna learn you're gonna learn a lot
more the default setting default state
as you put it in this case creates a
completely different experience of
reality
absolutely wet weather it's guilty until
proven innocent as you look at everyone
and anything around you or innocent till
proven guilty and I remember you're
talking about these one-liners these
shards that that stick in the mind I
remember it I can't I can't recall who
said this to me but they said if you go
out one day you walk around and you meet
an [ __ ] that person is an [ __ ] if
on the other hand you go out and
everyone you meet is an [ __ ]
you're the [ __ ] and if you assume
that everyone has negative intent you
yourself become that which you loathe
and I'd boy that's a really good point
and I like very good point I love that
assume positive intent well it also fits
on a billboard it does no that's the
other I was actually taking that thing
very literally it's like a literally
picturing in my head like what would be
what could what could what could fit on
the market what could fit on the
billboard well I think that's I think
that's a great place to wrap I mentioned
a few things at the top of the show
danping calm at Daniel pink on Twitter
Facebook Daniel H pink is there anything
else that you would like to mention as
closing comments requests and ask of the
audience anything else you would like to
say no I mean we've covered a lot we've
covered a lot of ground and you know if
people have listened this far god bless
them I mean I can't that's even I'm not
that in grateful to ask for something
more after this kind of indulgence well
I am a big fan of your work I hate
anything for a very long time and so I
including Johnny Bunco thank you which I
still have to this day so you may recall
ages ago lifetimes ago I think it was at
South by Southwest actually which is
timely since I now live in Austin Texas
you inscribed you signed a copy of that
book for me which I still have I've
carried it with I remember where we were
sitting
yeah I do so I appreciate it and I still
have the book and it's really been nice
to reconnect and catch up a bit in yeah
yeah it's been fun you know obviously
it's been fun to watch all the great
things that all the great things that
you're doing it just hi this is this
massive audience that you've built and
just you know I've gotten so much I have
a my dog ear you know it's too bad you
be done on video but I could show you my
dog-eared copy of tools of titans which
is a which is a great book title by the
way it is the only book title that came
easily it is the only one all the other
ones were agonizing
agonizing agonizing sessions of
brainstorming and picking a one of the
titles among many that I felt
dissatisfied with tools of titans for
whatever reason yeah thanks to the
universe or whatever powers that may be
or the reluctant me of happened upon me
but that that is one that just kind of
came and I was like oh yeah I know
that's that's the title and that was it
I didn't I also didn't realize that you
were in Austin how did you end up in
Austin robot end up in oh yeah it's I I
have felt a gravitational pull to Austin
for a very long time I in fact wanted to
move here right out of college but I
didn't get the job at trilogy software
made it to oh okay made it to a final
round of interviews which brought me out
to Austin really fell in love with the
town the the baseline of friendliness
and warmth here it's just a neighborly
feel is higher than just about any other
place I've experienced and then instead
of getting a job here I got a job in the
Bay Area which took me to San Jose
Mountain View in San Francisco for the
better part of nearly 20 years which I
loved for that period of time but much
like with books I think that you visit
places and your experience of those
places changes over time and what what
attracted me to the Bay Area I think has
has has morphed into something else and
then I have also morphed into someone
else and it's a lot it don't like I felt
like a good time for me to experiment
with a new location also I found myself
within the very almost inescapable
conversation of tech to be just drinking
the kool-aid a little too heavily or
repeat or believing my own [ __ ]
maybe not necessarily [ __ ] but
getting caught up in a lot of platitudes
that are thrown around so often in
Silicon Valley to have become part of
the daily vernacular and that scared me
quite frankly that I was like wait a
second if I look back at the last five
to six months how many conversations
have I had that don't include the
following twelve words for 12
expressions oh yeah wow I can actually
count them on on both hands
it's just interesting and what did you
grow up I corrupt at the very end of
Long Island and was born a townie in the
Hamptons which is a very odd thing I
think I said for anyone for anyone who's
seen the affair I I have not but I've
heard the affair in this TV show that is
apparently quite popular a lot of it
takes place in this restaurant called
the lobster roll which is in Montauk and
I used to be a busboy at Wow nice yes
the Long Island is is where this this I
do we really weirdly I remember from
4-hour workweek I think that you
described yourself as a Hellion Hellion
a little Hellion good memory which is a
great word it's such a great word yeah
yeah but I realized I didn't have any
Geographic sense of where you where you
where you grew up
yeah that's interest I think the use of
Hellion is actually in the dedication to
my parents and I think that's right I
think that's right you know why in one
reason I remember that is that I listen
to part I got part of that book on on
audiobook and I remember at the because
you read that book I'm almost certain
yeah it was Ray Porter who has has a
voice that is easily mistaken for my my
various mannerisms that I've developed
now via podcasting so that was that was
Ray Porter who did a great job
how I think okay yeah I'm pretty sure
that I but I know it's just a great work
it is a good it is a good day it's great
and I'm gonna try to use it in the next
24 hours when I have it when I come up
with a good when I hear a good word I
try to you I try to drop it in the next
24 hours just because it helps reinforce
it for me well I'm gonna try to use sir
again and I'm going to try to eat more
hard-boiled eggs in the next 24 hours
you're you're golden the life will
change markedly if you start employing
the principle Sergey ssin while eating
hard-boiled eggs
everything will your everything the Sun
will come shining up and the Sun look
will burst out from behind the clouds
and you know
unicorns will scamper across your front
lawn well my dog will love that and then
this has been this has been a lot of fun
thank you thanks a lot for having me I
appreciate it was a lot of really
interesting and for everybody listening
as always you can find links to
everything including dance social
website the new book when and much more
in the show notes which you can find at
end up log forward slash podcast and
until next time thanks for listening hey
guys this is Tim again just a few more
things before you take off number one
this is five bullet Friday do you want
to get a short email from me would you
enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode is brought to you by we work I
love we working I haven't had an office
in many many many many many years since
2000 or so when I had my last real job
dispose of quotation marks but when I
moved from San Francisco to Austin not
long ago I decided you know what I'm
tired of working at home I'm tired of
working at coffee shops so one of the
very first things I did was to get a
space that we work I could not be happy
this change in my life we work is a
global network of workspaces where
companies and people grow together the
idea is really simple
you focus on your business and we work
takes care of all the rest including
front desk service utilities
refreshments and I also often have that
ship Amazon and elsewhere to my office
at we work here in Austin I've been
completely blown away by the
members-only events special offers and
perhaps the best cold brew coffee on tap
than I've ever had it's been amazing
it's been a real real change in my life
and improved my quality of life and
there are also dog friendly we work
locations all over the place how fun is
that we work caters to everyone from
entrepreneurs and freelancers to
startups and even large enterprises
including GE Salesforce Microsoft
MasterCard Samsung Spotify Pinterest and
Red Bull among many others in fact more
than 10% of Fortune 500 companies
currently use we work and it's a rapidly
growing grid in other words it's not
just solar printers and the ground-level
startups they use we work but everything
from that to the big companies who are
seeing very huge benefits as well as we
work believes that creating spaces where
people can connect and create meaning
together right after all if you are
someone who's built a business model on
the principles of work week or elsewhere
it could be a lonely road sometimes even
though you're digitally connected it can
feel very very isolated
so in these spaces you can connect with
real humans and all the while use space
more efficiently and cost-effectively
which makes you and your business better
equipped to face the challenges of today
we work now has more than 200 locations
so you can find great spots all over the
world so head over to we co forward /
Tim of V Co Co we doc cohort / Tim to
become a part of the global we work
community at the very least I encourage
you to check out pictures of some of the
locations in the world there are some
incredible spots so check it out
we've Co for / Tim this episode is
brought to you by 4 Sigma Dec
you might remember 4 sig Matic for their
mushroom coffee which was created by
those clever Finnish founders and when I
first mentioned that coffee on this
podcast products sold out in less than a
week it lights you up like a Christmas
tree which can be really useful however
recently I've been testing the opposite
side of the spectrum a new product and
that is their reishi mushroom elixir to
help me end my day to get to sleep as
you guys may know longtime listeners at
least I struggled with insomnia for
decades
I will largely fix that but still
shutting off my monkey brain has never
been easy it still isn't easy very often
and I found reishi which have been
fascinated by it for a few years now has
been very very effective and calming
their old formula however for sig Maddox
old formula included stevia and I like
to avoid sweeteners all sweeteners for a
host of reasons and I then just ping
them and asked hey guys
I would love to experiment with this and
maybe actually suggest it but I'd like a
version without sweeteners if you'd be
open to it if 200 headache don't worry
and they are always game for
experimentation so they created a
special custom version without the
stevia without sweeteners now it is part
of my nightly routine their ratio elixir
comes in similar serving packets which
are perfect for travel and in fact I'm
about to leave the country right now and
I have a packet in front of me that's
just gonna sit in the end of my carry-on
you only need hot water and it mixes
very very easily
here are some recommended copy that they
put in the read so I'm gonna read it and
I'll give you my take quote a warning
for those in the experimental mindset
reishi is strong and bitter in
parentheses like any great medicine so
if the bitterness is too much I
recommend trying it with honey end or
nut milk such as almond milk and quote
so I'm gonna say no you should suck it
up and you should drink the tea because
it's not that bitter and maybe should
take the advice of all Chinese people
when they're criticizing youngins when
they say ooh and I'm sure it cool which
means you're not able to eat bitterness
bitter is in many cases an indication of
things that help liver detoxification
and so on not saying that's the case
here but I've tested this ratio chart on
family members on friends everybody is
liked it it's a little bit earthy it's
not that hard so I would just say suck
it up and no don't put in honey or nut
milk or any of that [ __ ] just drink the
goddamn tea it's delicious
I think right if you like to air that
kind of stuff that type of tea you're
gonna dig it so just try it okay back to
them my read if you'd like to naturally
improve your sleep
both on set and quality I think
naturally you might just enjoy this
ratio lecture without any sweeteners it
has organic reishi extract organic
fueled mint extract organic rosehips
extract organic Tulsi extract and that's
it no fancy stuff no artificial
whatchamacallit anything so check it out
go to for sig Matic compensation Ferriss
and get 20% off this special batch I
don't know if they're gonna be making
much more of this since it was made
specifically for you guys so do me a
favor and try it out so that they
continue to be open to experimenting
with me to create products for you guys
specifically check it out for sig Matic
that's fo you are SI g ma t IC comm /e
Ferriss f e RR ISS and get 20% off the
special batch and you must use
the code at Ferris to receive a discount
FBR Riss so again gonna force Sigma to
comport slash Paris and then use code of
Ferris for 20% off of this rare
exclusive limited run of reishi mushroom
elixir for nighttime routines with out
and sweepers enjoy
you